hi there everyone you've probably
noticed over the past few weeks I
haven't been producing any videos either
here on numberphile or my other channels
that's not some bad omen relating to the
fact our last film was about the number
in fact I've just been on holiday I
actually went and saw something I've
always wanted to see and that's Mount
Everest so before we get back into the
usual swing of things here on
numberphile I thought I'd share a few
number effects about the biggest
mountain in the world
so Mount Everest probably nudged its way
to become the world's highest mountain
about 200,000 years ago but of course it
wasn't recognized as such until about
the mid 1800s during the great trigger
nemetrix survey of india peering into
the Forbidden Lands of Nepal and Tibet
from nearly 200 miles away I should say
survey is calculated what they called
peak B or peak 15 to be exactly 29,000
feet high now they didn't think anyone
would believe it was exactly 29,000 feet
high so they published a height of
29,000 and two feet that's eight
thousand eight hundred and forty meters
now the British weren't really too clear
on what the local names were for the
mountain and that's still a reasonably
complicated debate today so they decided
they'd name it after the former survey
boss a guy called George Everest or
Everest as we call it these days
now in the mid 1950s not long after the
mountain had been climbed for the first
time it was remarried and the more
accurate height of 8,848 meters was
adopted that's the familiar number many
of us know today more precise
measurements were made in the 1990s and
things didn't change very much still
about 8,848 meters but in 1999 some
Americans came along using GPS and they
put a spanner in the works publishing a
new height 8850 meters for many
people that still stands then in 2005
the Chinese came along and published a
lower figure eight thousand eight
hundred and forty four meters they said
the snow cap on top of the mountain
shouldn't be counted and they were using
the rocky summit instead now Nepal
doesn't accept this argument they're
sticking with 8,848 now more
measurements are planned at the moment
these things are always going on and
it's also worth noting that Mount
Everest is actually growing by about
half a centimetre one centimetre every
year as the indian continental plate
smashes into china forcing the himalayas
up in fact in about a million years
everest would theoretically be twice as
told as it is now but gravity and
earthquakes things like that are
unlikely to allow that to happen
and of course everest is only the king
of the mountains when measuring above
sea level the highest mountain measured
from its base to its summer is actually
Mauna Kea in Hawaii most of this
mountain of course is below the sea and
the furthest point from the center of
the earth is actually the peak of this
mountain in Ecuador which benefits from
the Earth's bulging waistline but
whatever the numbers say whatever
definitions you like it's always going
to be Mount Everest that captures the
imagination of people like me now
there's a few numbers and figures about
Mount Everest but that's enough of my
holiday photos and next numberphile
video will be back to business as usual